Tesla's thirty billion dollar market
value is built on a dream that a
start-up car maker might somehow be able
to crank out half a million all-electric
vehicles a year by 2020 however last
week
Tesla lowered its sales forecast for
2015 and 2016 causing many to question
how CEO Elon Musk still thinks he can go
from 50 thousand sales this year to five
hundred thousand five years later the
problem with placing bets on Tesla's
future is that there are very few
examples to compare it to when has
another startup tried to build an
entirely new kind of automobile one that
requires a complete reconfiguration of
the industrial process there's really
only one example the original game
changer the Ford Model T here's Tesla's
vehicle production so far and it's
forecast for this year and next and here
is Musk's goal for 500,000 cars by 2020
it seems like a stretch but now look at
this
line up that data with the Ford model-t
sales beginning in 1909 the matchup is
striking by 1916 the Model T hit Musk's
goal with precision producing five
hundred and one thousand four hundred
and sixty two cars Tesla is already
making some of the fastest running cars
in the world
now all it has to do is keep up with the
Model T